-Unbelievable.
She is my jam.
Our next guest won Grammy awards
for Best New Artist
and Best Jazz Vocal Album.
Performing
"Guess Who I Saw Today,"
from her album "Linger Awhile,"
please welcome, Samara Joy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ You're so late ♪
♪ Getting home from the office ♪
♪♪
♪ Did you miss your train? ♪
♪ Were you caught in the rain? ♪
♪ No ♪
♪ Don't bother ♪
♪ Don't bother to explain ♪
♪ Can I fix you ♪
♪ A quick martini ♪
♪ As a matter of fact ♪
♪ I'll have one with you ♪
♪ For to tell you the truth ♪
♪ I've had ♪
♪ Quite a day, too ♪
♪♪
♪ Guess who I saw today,
my dear ♪
♪ I went in town ♪
♪ To shop around
for something new ♪
♪ And I thought I'd stop ♪
♪ And grab a bite
when I was through ♪
♪ I looked around ♪
♪ For someplace new ♪
♪ Then it occurred to me ♪
♪ Where I had parked the car ♪
♪ There was a most
attractive French café and bar ♪
♪ It really wasn't very far ♪
♪ The waiter showed me ♪
♪ To a dark, secluded corner ♪
♪ As my eyes became accustomed
to the gloom ♪
♪ I saw two people at the bar ♪
♪ Who were so much in love ♪
♪ Even I could spot it
clear across the room ♪
♪ Guess who I saw today,
my dear ♪
♪ I'd never been
so shocked before ♪
♪ I headed blindly
through the door ♪
♪ They didn't see me
passing through ♪
♪ Guess who I saw today ♪
♪ Guess who I saw t-o-o-oday ♪
♪ I ♪
♪ Saw ♪
♪ You ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]